hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
HD stands for high definition which is
short for lots of pixels the more pixels
the better so as you can imagine the
high definition or high resolution
phones out there tend to provide an
experience just a step above all the
other phones the highest resolution
phones that we're seeing right now are
at a resolution of 1920 by 1080 so as
you can imagine we're going to take a
look at the best of them today we're
going to count down the top 5 best 1080p
smartphones right now
five is the Sony spare uz /zl this is
one of the best looking phones of the
year it's pretty much the hands-down
number-one for design so if you're
counting down best design phones I would
have to give that number one it is a
water-resistant phone and it's actually
a really fast phone to so it's a really
handsome and really speedy device which
is why people like it so much when I
reviewed it I kind of deemed it a bit of
a mixed bag though if you want to watch
the full reviews to any of these they
will be linked down below the like
button but the main flaw with the Sony
Xperia Z was the display it didn't have
the best contrast in the world and it
had subpar viewing angles so we couldn't
give that the best score possible or I
couldn't give that the best score
possible but it's definitely a very good
looking phone and it easily takes number
five on this list because of the raw
speed and the handsomeness number four
is the HTC butterfly this is also known
in the United States as the Droid DNA
it's a red and black version and it's
the first 1080p phone with LTE now we
would also expect to have a 1080p phone
with LTE have a huge battery but it
didn't it had a 2020 milliamp hour
battery so that was probably his biggest
weakness in battery life but overall it
was again a very well-built HTC phone it
had a polycarbonate back very nice
basically unibody construction it felt
great in the hand and of course had an
awesome 1080p display so that was the
pretty much the primer for getting 1080p
phones going in the United States it was
basically first in the US and that's why
it was so popular immediately on Verizon
and the butterfly is really popular now
worldwide so the HTC butterfly is a
great looking phone as well it came with
sense for plus not sense 5 so it's not
the newest version of sense but we'll
get to that later but yeah it's a pretty
solid phone it takes a spot over the
Sony Xperia Z because that is a much
better
1080p panel number three is the Oppo
find 5 now this is actually technically
the first 1920 by 1080 display I first
did a video about this before the idea
was even out there and 1080p displays on
phones were sort of unheard of a bit
unrealistic but this was first and it
brought itself first to China and the
Apple fine 5 is a dream on the spec
sheet they Hardware lineup that they put
into this phone is absurd it's insane
it's made out of completely steel it's a
unibody construction again has a 13
megapixel camera the Snapdragon s4 pro
had the
this version of Android when it came out
just an all-around awesome beast of a
device it's still catching up on the
hardware and sorry the software front
because well it doesn't have sense or
TouchWiz or anything doesn't have years
of experience with software to grow on
so they're just now getting back into it
with project Firefly getting back on the
road for increasing in terms of value
with software so I don't have the years
of experience that you see your Samsung
might have with building on software but
the Apple flying 5 is a damn good phone
on the hardware front and that's why it
takes all around number 3 so number 2 is
the Samsung Galaxy s4 this is one of the
most anticipated phones of the year 2013
you could argue that the galaxy s3 was
the phone of the year for 2012 so the
galaxy s4 follows up with a really
really powerful smartphone first of all
it is an 8 core CPU in the international
version the I 9500 is a boss on paper
has a 2500 milliamp hour battery has a
13 megapixel camera you could argue that
this is the perfect phone - some very
very small complaints that have been
called odd about it number one is it's
still an AMOLED display so it's not the
brightest display outdoors you can take
the galaxy s3 and another IPS phone
outside and you'll see that the galaxy
s3 whether it's AMOLED display is not
nearly as bright as something like the
Oppo fine 5 which has a much brighter
IPS display so the one big complaint
about it was the dimness of the AMOLED
displays and the other big complaint
about it was the build quality and it's
still made of that same Samsung plastic
now the galaxy s3 had a sort of hyper
glazed finish on the back so it was
definitely slippery and you could tell
and feel that it was plastic it was thin
it was flexible it was cheap the galaxy
s4 has a slightly different finish but
it's still plastic so it's hard to tell
that if it's a major improvement or not
outside of that those are the only two
main complaints about the galaxy s4
outside of yet it's a really impressive
phone on the hardware front that's why
it takes number two that means number
one is the HTC One every single review
of this phone has been glowingly
positive because this thing is off the
charts good on the hardware front and on
the software front if you see one is so
good that the biggest complaint about it
is tends to be the fact that it's sealed
in so you can't replace the
battery and the fact that the camera is
only four megapixels I've done a
separate video on why the cameras only
four megapixels so if you want to check
that out there's a reason there but
that's the biggest complaint about the
HTC One it is an awesome all-around
phone on the hardware side because it
has a large battery and all aluminum
build it has a really really rock-solid
processor just this knife rack in six
hundred kills benchmarks if you haven't
already seen so is an awesome phone
coming to the United States and on
software side of things HTC Sense 5 is
brand new it runs on the latest version
of Android 4 it's really good and it's
it's probably a big reason why the HTC
One is going to be the flagship for HTC
all year so the overall package of
completing awesome hardware that's just
compelling and good and feels good in
the hand and just rock solid plus the
software side of things where people
actually want to pick up the phone and
play with it because the software is
awesome
make the HTC One pretty much the best
1080p phone out there right now plus
it's a 4.7 inch display all the other
phones on this list are 5 inch displays
they're 5-inch 1080p phones this one is
a 4.7 inch 1920 by 1080 p panel which
gives it the highest pixel density of
any of the ones here so if you want to
talk about HD that is a seriously high
definition phone right there so there
you go guys those are the top 5 1080p
phones out right now you may have
noticed something about this list every
single phone on this list that I just
mentioned is an Android phone there were
no iPhones on this list there were no
windows phones on this list there were
no blackberries on this list and that's
because there are no 1080p blackberries
there are no 1080p iPhones and there are
no 1080p windows phones and that's just
the nature of pushing the pace when you
have manufacturers developing on an open
platform I hope we'll see 1080p Windows
Phone soon I think we'll probably see a
1080p iPhone somewhere in the next two
years don't know if we'll see a 1080p
blackberry but definitely keep an eye
out the horizon I'll say is open we
don't exactly know what all these
manufacturers have up their sleeves or
if we're going to see even higher
resolution phones down the line also a
common question or common comment I get
I just want to say are people saying do
we really need 1080p phones do we
actually need a phone with such a high
pixel
city no you don't need a phone with such
high pixel density but it's damn
good-looking and you better believe that
it looks better than a 720p phone that's
for sure so that's it that's the end of
the video if you agree with this list
definitely let me know below or if you
don't let me know why what was your
number one maybe it was different
definitely leave a comment down below
that like button but I'll be checking
them out you can see me replying down
below thanks for watching guys and I
will talk to you guys in the next video
you